yo what is up everybody mad Luigi here
with some more fallout 4 calm 10 now in
this video i'm gonna be showing you guys
how to get the perception bobblehead
which gives you +1 permanently into your
perception special stat and the robco
fun comic that comes with the atomic
command minigame for your pip-boy so
what you're gonna want to do is head to
concord which is in the northwest corner
of the maps you can head there big
pretty easy you to spot city just get on
the main road find the Museum of Liberty
it's like the big big building at the
end of the road can't miss it giant
building center of the road easy to see
can head on in there and what you're
going to want to do is progress to the
top floor and go to the room that's
closest to the front of the building on
the top floor there should be some
raiders here and this is also where you
meet Preston gravy gravy if you know
that area and that's where you gonna
head up if you don't know that area just
go through the building killing all the
Raiders once you get to the top floor
ahead to the room that is closest to the
front of the building so as soon as you
walk in the room the Rob Kofun issues
gonna be on the first desk that you see
to your right it's gonna be right there
easy to pick up easy to see and then the
perception bobbleheads going to be over
to the left way across the room on the
other desk again it's going to be way
out and you open easy to see and boom
you have the rhabdo fun magazine and you
have the perception bobblehead so that's
basically it for the guy this is pretty
easy to get it is pretty easy to see as
well however I'm just making this in
case you didn't see it whether you were
playing the main storyline or maybe you
didn't play in the main storyline you
don't know these are here so I hope you
guys have enjoyed this and yeah we'll be
making a lot more guides on bobbleheads
magazines and fallout 4 just in general
so if you're looking for that stick
around at my channel thank you for
watching peace out